tell us what a
your reaction is to the the scenes we're
seeing not just in wennington there are
other fires burning on your patch and uh
the fact that a major incident has been
declared by the london fire brigade
well i've been regular i've been in
regular contact during the course of
today with the london fire commissioner
and the team at the london fire brigade
and i've just come off the phone
with the london fire commissioner andy
rowe uh the london fire brigade have
declared a major incident because of the
pressure
on the london
fire brigade to give you an idea
of the challenges we're facing in our
capital city on a normal day
the london fire brigade would receive
between 300 and 350 calls for assistance
today already they've received more than
1600 calls for assistance
some of the fires you've seen during the
course of today these horrible images
you're showing some have required more
than 35 engines some have required 20
fire engines some required 15 some 10.
the reason why uh we've called a major
incident is we simply can't cope with
the number of fires across our city
directly attributable
to the heat wave we're experiencing the
dry grass you've heard about
the way the fire spreads during the uh
this uh the heat wave and the real
challenge we have
is some of these these fires could have
been prevented by us changing our
behavior so the message from the
commissioner is quite simple no
barbecues please today or tomorrow if
you're out and about and you are a
smoker please be very very careful how
you do with your extinguished cigarette
if there's glass or bottles near grass
they magnify the heat they can lead to
these grass fights and they spread
so fast and please if you're near water
and you're tempted to cool yourself down
by jumping in the water whether it's a
thames a canal or a waterway please
don't uh because it's really dangerous
not just the cold water shot but it
requires fire fighters as well as others
to try and rescue you so it's a really
difficult time and we're asking for all
londoners those across the country to
change your routines to make sure we
don't cause a situation with a fire
brigade that can't cope so just to be
clear here mr mayor
you're calling for no barbecuing at all
in london for for the next day even if
this is in your back garden on a on a
gas fire barbecue on on some concrete or
something like that and no while
swimming you don't put any more
potential pressure on the fire services
right can i be quite clear about this
these are direct questions i asked the
loan flight commissioner
is what i accept and it is please no
barbecues today or tomorrow this is not
about us being in any state or party
poopers it's the reality of accidents
happening and fires starting and
spreading rapidly and these prize these
fires can spread rapidly in your garden
plants
deck in homes and so forth uh people
have been having barbecues in parks no
you can't have barbecues in the bark and
definitely on your balconies even on
your private gardens uh today or
tomorrow these temperatures we're
experiencing approaching 40 degrees the
dry grass we are seeing is leading to
the sorts of horrible images that we're
seeing on sky news uh now so
the message from me
from the london fire commissioner is no
barbecues today please look i i we all
want to enjoy good weather this weather
is dangerous though the chief medical
officer himself said
this weather poses a threat to life and
not just those who are older not just
those who are vulnerable so it's
dangerous directly i've been in this
weather but also it's a danger because
you could inadvertently start a a fire
and i appreciate the temptation
of jumping in water when it's really
really hot but i'm afraid not just the
cold water shock but also some of the
tidal waves and some of the other
challenges uh a 14 year old boy uh his
body was found today who jumped in the
water yesterday with his uh best friend
his best friend was rescued uh this 14
year old child lost his life we want no
more loss of life but also we need the
london fire brigade to be assisted by us
by doing the right thing
so just on that swimming i mean tragic
as these terrible incidents are mr mayor
even if you've been wild swimming as the
as the phrase now is you know
the stretch of water
you know exactly what the conditions are
just don't do it for the next few days
can i come at this point look accidents
happen not deliberately right people get
into trouble when they're swimming not
intentionally
and the point is at this stage i can't
hand in heart say there'll be a fire
fighter who'll be able to jump in and
save you or a lifeguard to be able to
jump in and save you if you're getting
to bother
and you know these tragedies we've had
over the last few days a 14 year old
child yesterday a 16 year old child two
three days ago neither of them intended
to have serious injuries themselves or
losing their lives and so i am asking
people
not to be tempted to have fun buy a
family barbecue in their back garden
tonight or by jumping into water uh
tonight the london fire brigade do not
call a major incident lightly the number
of incidents they're responding to is
almost five-fold what they normally have
to deal with
we've
asked the fire service to council leave
their council leave they brought in
staff those who were doing other things
have stopped doing other things all the
engines that can be out are being out
but there's the difference between a six
minute response and a 20-minute response
is the difference potentially between
life and death and all your personal
possessions being lost so i am saying uh
no barbecues tonight on the basis of the
advice i am saying don't jump into the
river thames or canals or waterways
is really really important we do what we
can to get through this heat wave
without unnecessary deaths without
unnecessary damage to our properties
what is a direct consequence of climate
change
and given just how extensively resources
are stretched as you describe them there
mr gunn
should people be alarmed that i suppose
i may attempt the the regular cover that
they expect from the fire service
is simply not there at the moment
they're
too
busy they're too occupied with these
wildfires that we're seeing
well let me explain the scale of
challenge so normally what happens is
fire services require what's called
mutual aid and in the past we've replied
we've relied on mutual aid the flash
floods this time last year fire services
outside london could help the fire
brigade all 10 of the fire services
outside of london that would normally
help london are themselves so stretched
they can't afford to send anybody and
they're asking for help from london
that's how bad things are in the south
of our country as a direct consequence
of these heat waves and the problem is
if you and i were speaking 10-15 years
ago we'd be talking about heat waves
happening every 10 20 years these heat
waves are happening every one or two
years and the temperatures we're now
reaching of almost 40 degrees are
temperatures we're not used to
and my concern also according to
speaking the advice from the met office
it's possible
the fires today the excessive heat today
could be followed over the next couple
of days by extreme rainfall leading to
flash flooding and again it's a fire
service who will have no respite
responding to this so we need to do what
we can to take some some of the pressure
off the fire service uh you know over
the next 24 hours and do what we can to
give them respite but also to avoid the
images you're showing of people's
property being destroyed and people
potentially being injured or even worse
losing their lives
just lastly give your us your overview
mr mayor um you know this is uh a
government we know the changing prime
minister at the moment that held cop 26
what just
nine ten months ago yet now during the
course of this leadership debate don't
seem to be discussing the climate
emergency at all it's more about
tax cuts
what i find astonishing
is that this conservative leadership
contest is taking place
during the
worst heat wave in terms of temperatures
reaching that i've experienced in my
lifetime
and all the experts agree by the way
it's unarguable that this heat wave
we're experiencing across europe is a
direct consequence of climate change
what the those aspiringly that prime
minister should be doing is setting out
their plans to address the symptoms the
adaptations the resilience as a
consequence of climate change the fires
you're seeing the flash flooding we may
all seen as well as dealing with the
causes of climate change as well rather
than kicking the can down the road when
it comes to tackling climate change we
should be sprinting towards getting to
net zero and by the way
having sustainable forms of energy wind
and solar means we're not relying
upon upon stuff from russia or qatar or
saudi so it reduces the price
of our bills but also by retrofitting
adapting our homes
places of work at public transport it
creates jobs in this country jobs are
you know in west yorkshire in balamina
in falkor making these buses baking the
air cooling systems fitting the extra
vehicle charging points and so it's a
virtuous circle and so it beggars
believe to me for anybody who aspires to
be the leader of our great countries
understand
that the crisis we face in terms of
what's happening today in relation to
the fires
excessive
excess deaths but also the causes of
this as well
just give us a sense then
from a labor government's perspective of
the scale
of that investment you described there
preparing for the future getting to that
carbon-free future as quickly as
possible we know it's going to take
several decades at least the scale of
that investment while also
dealing with the here and now trying to
prevent the scenes that we're witnessing
right here
right now that we're discussing that
resilience so to speak every single home
in the country every single city has to
have major investment
well look one of the reasons people have
large energy bills is because their
homes could be poorly insulated they
have a double glazing they rely upon
fossil fuels and there's a lack of
security around fossil fuels what we
should be doing to reduce bills that
people are worried about ordinary
families across the country is to make
their homes more energy efficient
insulate their homes put double glazing
in make sure the supply comes from
renewable sources of energy which will
create jobs
so tax revenues will come in from people
who are working who are underemployed
high skilled well-paid jobs we can be
exporting some of this innovation across
the globe but also reducing people's
bills addressing the cost of living
crisis and by the way
those who
talk all the time about their concerns
around these channel crossings one of
the ways to
you know
reduce
people leaving the global south coming
to the global
north is by addressing the issue of
climate displacement by tackling that
root cause you know climate change that
means less droughts
less you know
rising waters in countries like
bangladesh and so forth and so i don't
understand why anybody who you know
seeks high office doesn't appreciate
that we should be dealing with the
causes of climate change and at the same
time you know the the consequences
including investing in the fire service
invested in
public transport investing in
our homes invested in solar and
wind supporting pensioners who are
choosing between turning or turning on a
fan
or eating
sports and pensions in the winter who
will be choosing between heating and
eating those parents who are choosing
between skipping the meal themselves so
they can feed their kids because of lack
of security in relation to food and
energy these are big problems that
actually if we address them can deal
with the problems we're facing today
cost of living energy prices what are
you seeing in your screens
mr mayor a wide-ranging interview thank
you very much indeed for granting it to
us uh sally khan there
the mayor of london